[Música]
hablamos de salud en directo américa por
supuesto con más romeros a la mara
bienvenida feliz mañana de viernes hoy
vamos a dedicar todo este espacio para
hablar de la pandemia 19 en el
continente africano mar que sabemos
entonces de la crisis de salud pública
en áfrica buenos días raúl pues no sé si
recuerdas cuando empezó la pandemia
tanto los expertos como la población
general teníamos mucho miedo de lo que
podía suceder cuando la pandemia de kobe
19 llegara a africanos todos teníamos
unas ciertas expectativas de catástrofe
sin embargo con el tiempo se ha visto
que pues al menos no ha sido peor quizás
ha sido igual o mejor que en otros
lugares del mundo pero no ha sido peor y
pues alrededor de esos datos han crecido
varias teorías y varias hipótesis
alrededor de por qué no ha sido tan
devastadora la pandemia en el continente
africano como en otros lugares por un
lado ha habido el debate de si es la
manera en que se han registrado las
muertes o los contagios de kobe 19
también por la juventud de la población
que definitivamente ha jugado un papel
por las distintas maneras de socializar
de distintas poblaciones africanas pero
es que se ha llegado a pensar incluso en
que había algún tipo de también pues
genética en las poblaciones del
continente africano que podían
protegerlos contra el 19 y también me
acuerdo la incertidumbre cuando se
detectó por primera vez esta variante
delta creo que fue en sudáfrica no mar y
omicron de hecho las dos se detectaron
algo mismo beta fue la que se detectó en
sudáfrica perdón y omic con tantas
variantes ya yo me confundo pero que
ayer tomar entonces en todas estas
explicaciones pues la verdad es que a
ciencia cierta todavía no se puede saber
y un gran problema es porque no hay
investigación no parece que como al
final la población africana no murió
como todos nos esperábamos pues no se
tiene que investigar cómo se está
desarrollando la pandemia en ese
continente entonces pero bueno por un
lado digamos que hay un cierto consenso
alrededor de que la juventud de la
población ha jugado un factor de la
misma manera que ha jugado un factor
también en otras en otros lugares del
mundo se lo preguntamos también a
catherine que wood un beat que es
directora del centro de investigación de
la población y salud en áfrica y ella
nos hablaba también de los distintos de
las distintas preparaciones de los
sistemas de salud escuchemos lo que
explicaba
de ministros o help acepta su esposa
expreso los ministerios de salud están
preparados para enfatizar la preparación
he vivido un brote de ébola y en casos
así todo el mundo está en alerta incluso
con un solo caso o lorbek y menguar que
son de pola de gordón de atroz o en
brotes de cólera que son más frecuentes
que los de ébola todo el mundo estaba en
alerta extrema los sistemas están listos
para responder a la crisis de salud
pública response to crisis aplique a los
países es importante reconocer la
experiencia que sí tienen los sistemas
de salud africanos frente a crisis de
salud aunque también es importante
recordar que es muy distinto un brote
localizado como puede ser de ébola o de
cólera que una pandemia generalizada
entonces con todo eso más repasamos las
cifras que tenemos sobre la pandemia en
ese continente exacto estábamos diciendo
que no tenemos mucha información pero
vamos a repasar la que si tenemos en
cualquier caso los contagios y las
muertes que se han registrado por
competición han sido muy bajas en
comparación con otras regiones del mundo
sin embargo la organización mundial de
la salud publicó un aglomerado de
estudios y básicamente la conclusión a
la que llegó es que habían encontrado
anticuerpos a fecha de septiembre de
2021 en 800 millones de personas en el
continente africano mientras que los
contagios reportados son sólo 8 millones
eso significa que hay 97 veces más
personas que han estado contagiadas de
con 19 expuestas al virus de las que
están reportadas en las cifras oficiales
una de las principales conclusiones
también es que dos tercios de la
población africana han sido contagiadas
o han pasado por el commit 19 también
revisemos lo que llamamos el exceso de
muertes no todas esas muertes que no se
han registrado como muertes de kobe 19
pero que en comparación con la mortandad
oficial en otros años no pandémicos pues
podemos ver si hay alguna diferencia en
todo el lado se han reportado cifras más
bajas de muertes por como 19 que las
reales pero es que la diferencia en el
continente africano también es mayúscula
según cifras y estimados de the
economist podrían haber llegado a 3
millones de muertes las que se han
registrado en el continente africano
mientras que las cifras oficiales no
llegan a 300.000 eso significaría que
áfrica podría estar en un nivel de
mortandad parecido latina oa europa
aunque es verdad que cuando lo tenemos
en cuenta con la población sigue siendo
menor no son en áfrica unos 220 muertes
por cada 100.000 habitantes mientras que
eso puede ser hasta el doble en europa
claro y al final marc yo creo que una
pandemia pues va a ser difícil saber a
ciencia exacta el número de personas que
murieron digamos alrededor del mundo en
todo el mundo pues es difícil hacerlo
pero como podemos explicar entonces
estas diferencias de las cifras
obviamente volviendo al continente
africano sí pues hay dos versiones
incluso dentro de la misma comunidad
científica no por un lado los que
defienden como decíamos que la gente se
ha contagiado igual pero no se ha muerto
igual es decir que se han contagiado de
kobe pero no han enfermado o no se han
muerto no han necesitado hospitalización
de la misma manera debido a esas
hipótesis que decíamos antes la
socialización a la juventud o la
inmunidad previa a algunos coronavirus
pero hay otras versiones que defienden
que no hay nada que haga especial a los
africanos y eso es lo que defiende por
ejemplo salim abdul karim que es
profesor de salud global del centro
caprisa escuchemos
si los pacientes no se enferman y no
necesitan atención o se enferman pero no
tienen manera de acceder a la atención
médica y sobrecargar el sistema
hospitalario
lo que hemos visto es una combinación de
los dos factores por un lado malos
sistemas de registro y por otro lado
menos acceso a la salud
eso significa simplemente que los que
estamos en africanos infectamos como
todos nos enfermamos como todos los
demás en áfrica
williams williams y like necesitamos
oxígeno igual que todos y morimos igual
que todos los we just like a dios es
importante recordar que el doctor ha
sido uno de los principales
investigadores del cbit en sudáfrica es
sudafricano y pues también punta de
lanza de la lucha contra o micro en
cuando se descubrió esa variante en el
país así es mari bueno es que
lamentablemente en la campaña vacunación
en áfrica sigue avanzando muy lentamente
melero es la última arista que nos falta
por analizar aunque si está avanzando ha
habido incluso algunas voces que han
criticado que se prioriza la vacunación
de kobe 19 viendo que en áfrica no está
siendo una emergencia según ciertas
perspectivas como en otros lugares del
mundo pero bueno por un lado ya vemos
que esto se puede rebatir y por otro
lado por ejemplo también para tanto para
los dos expertos que hemos entrevistado
es básico que áfrica tenga las vacunas
por muchos motivos escuchemos como lo
defendía la doctora
mi mayor preocupación es como el debate
alrededor del cob y de largo está
ausente del discurso de vacunación
incluso los casos leves de covite pueden
llevar a kobe largo y eso conlleva
problemas de corazón de páncreas de
riñón de cerebro charles orser son
también problemas y dejar del ipauss de
frank y así decir mismo de print en un
sistema donde las enfermedades no
transmisibles no tienen recursos eso
puede suponer una carga gigante es
importante recordar también que hay
muchas cosas que no sabemos del comité
una vez desde el commit largo no podría
todavía sobrecargar más unos sistemas de
salud que no están preparados para este
tipo de crisis marc muchísimas gracias
entonces nuevamente